Який стосунок мають 87 центів до багатомільйонної виборчої кампанії?
Що ось такі виробники роблять на заходах політичних партій?
І чому ця неонацистська партія отримує фінансування від німецької держави?!
Це все пов'язано з тим, як у Німеччині фінансуються політичні партії.
Загальні принципи цього партійного та фінансового регулювання - вони справедливі, або, принаймні, добре сплановані.
Але ми вже бачили, що було багато лазівок і що системою можна маніпулювати.
У Німеччині немає обмежень щодо того, скільки партії можуть витратити на передвиборчу агітацію.
Деякі з них можуть витрачати значно більше, ніж інші.
Ось якою була диспропорція на останніх федеральних виборах у 2017 році.
Ви можете чітко бачити: дві найбільші партії - християнські демократи (ХДС) та соціал-демократи (СДПН) -
витратили щонайменше втричі більше, ніж менші партії.
Щоб повністю це зрозуміти, повернемося до монет, адже мова йде про підрахунок кожного цента.
Ось ключові джерела фінансування німецьких політичних партій:
членські внески, збори, які сплачують депутати, пожертвування та "інші" джерела, такі як спонсорство, активи, акції, публікації та виступи...
А також ще одне велике джерело - державне фінансування.
Ця система має зробити фінансування партій справедливим, прозорим та надати партіям рівні можливості. І це працює так:
Чим більше голосів отримує партія, тим більше грошей від держави вона отримує.
Громадська підтримка вимірюється трьома речами: голосами, членськими внесками та пожертвами.
За кожен голос, який здобуває партія, вона також отримує від держави 87 центів.
За перші чотири мільйони голосів це число навіть трохи більше: 1 євро 6 центів за голос.
Потім за кожен євро, отриманий партією як членський внесок, також нараховується від держави ще 45 центів.
Це правило 45-ти центів за євро також застосовується до особистих пожертв - пожертв від людей, а не від компаній.
Але є обмеження: ці 45 центів можна отримати лише за пожертви не більше 3300 євро на людину на рік.
Крім того, є обмеження на загальну суму державного фінансування.
У 2021 році ця межа була встановлена на рівні 200 049 468 євро.
Невеликі партії також мають зиск від цієї системи.
У них може бути менше прихильників, але вони все одно збирають голоси, членські внески та пожертви -
і відповідно до того, що ми щойно дізналися, це означає: вони отримують гроші від держави.
Ось приклад:
Минулого року неонацистська партія NPD отримала від німецької держави 370 632 євро 85 центів.
Це дуже мала сума порівняно з тим, що отримують більші партії, але багатьом німцям це не подобається.
Тому що NPD визнано антиконституційною.
Є спроби припинити надходження державних грошей до NPD.
Уряд звернувся до Верховного суду країни з проханням позбавити державного фінансування крайніх правих.
Але, здається, суд не дуже поспішає... Це було у 2019 році, і ми все ще чекаємо на вирок.
Це лише одна з проблем у системі, критики вказують й на інші лазівки.
Бракує прозорості, немає меж фінансового впливу. Наприклад, пожертви політичним партіям не мають юридичного максимуму.
Так, справді: у Німеччині немає обмежень щодо суми, яку партії можуть прийняти як пожертви.
Щоб краще зрозуміти це, подивімося на деталі: є різні правила прозорості для малих, середніх та великих пожертвувань.
Пожертви до 500 євро можуть залишатися анонімними.
Якщо пожертви перевищують 10 000 євро, партії мають публічно оголосити, звідки вони надійшли.
Вони це роблять у своїх щорічних звітах.
Втім, проблема полягає в тому, що звіти зазвичай з'являються з дуже тривалою затримкою… аж від одного до двох років.
Тільки пожертви понад 50 000 мають бути негайно задекларовані.
Ще одна лазівка в системі пов’язана з ось цими брендами та багатьма іншими галузевими гравцями та представниками бізнесу.
Замість того, щоб робити великі пожертви, великі компанії часто "спонсорують" події.
Наприклад, виробник автомобілів, який демонструє свою продукцію на партійній конференції
і відповідно може налагоджувати зв’язки з політиками.
При цьому спонсорство не повинно зазначатися у фінансових звітах партії.
І це справді дратує. З мого погляду, ця спонсорська діяльність все ще захована у цій статті доходів від інших видів діяльності у щорічних звітах партій.
А це означає, що вона невидима, інакше кажучи: непрозора.
Це підводить нас до іншої проблеми - органу, який має перевіряти, чи дотримуються партії правил і штрафувати їх, якщо ні.
Критики стверджують, що це відомство не відповідає поставленим цілям.
Наприклад, воно не може ретельно розслідувати діяльність партій.
Це також і під контролем голови Бундестагу, який теж належить до політичної партії - до християнських демократів Анґели Меркель.
Тож є ймовірність конфлікту інтересів.
Отже, нам потрібно просто покращити систему як таку, зробити наглядовий орган більш незалежним від політики
та визнати, що пожертвування, які перевищують щонайменше 10 000 євро, дійсно можуть робити вплив.
І тому одразу треба ідентифікувати того, хто пожертвував.
Під час розгляду деталей стає зрозумілим: у системі є багато лазівок й експерти кажуть,
що усунення цих прогалин зробить фінансування партій справедливішим.
Але для цьогорічних виборів вже занадто пізно, щоб стались якісь зміни.
Те, що має значення зараз для партій та їхніх банківських рахунків -
це набрати якомога більше голосів 26 вересня, тому що центи справді нараховуються…